That brings us to this specific lesson
that we're going to cover in this lecture. DFS
wants to intelligently use the cluster memory
for the efficient management of the metadata associated
with the files. And for caching the
file content cooperatively among the nodes of the
cluster for satisfying future requests for files.
In other words, what we would like to
do, is since we know that a disk is slow, we would like to avoid going to the
disk as much as possible. And retrieve the data from the memory of a peer in the
network if in fact that peer has previously
accessed the same file. And that's the idea behind
cooperative caching of files. But in order to fully
appreciate the question that we're asking and the answer
that we're going to discuss in this lesson,
it is important that you have a very good
understanding of file systems. If you don't have
it, don't worry. We have supporting lectures that will
help you get up to speed, and you can get this knowledge by diving into a good
under graduate textbook that covers this material well.
And the textbook that is used in the under
graduate systems course CS 2200 at Georgia Tech is a good resource for that.